[Music]
hold on
building after building
disintegrating
in the aftermath of one of the deadliest
earthquakes in turkey's history
measuring 7.8 in magnitude and 18
kilometers in depth
this earthquake was shallow and Powerful
the worst possible combination
and it struck at 17 minutes past four in
the morning as many slept in their beds
the moment that changed so many millions
of lives captured here on CCTV
[Applause]
[Music]
what came next was almost Beyond
imagination
foreign
their world had been transformed into
the most horrific landscape
multiple-story buildings flattened
whole streets destroyed within seconds
the southern Turkish city of gazientep
was this earthquake's epicenter
but its shock waves caused destruction
across Southern turkey and neighboring
Syria
search and rescue teams began the near
impossible locating those trapped under
the rubble
quickly
relentlessly the death toll Rose from
hundreds to thousands to tens of
thousands
and then just nine hours after the first
a second shallow quake
measuring 7.5 magnitude
it's Tremors felt across the Middle East
for The Rescuers it was just what they
didn't need around 45 minutes ago there
was an Aftershock of you know more than
six points magnitude and he did cause a
certain extra damage not just only
hampering the rescue airports because I
did see on my way this is my second
visit here some of the buildings that
were that looked fine before were also
damaged
this is the second biggest earthquake in
the last century as also government
officials said I have I myself agree
with my family it was around four
o'clock uh all of a sudden uh quiet
night became a chaos the epicenter of
Monday morning's Quake was here in the
southern Turkish city of gaziente it
lasted around a hundred seconds and
traveled about 400 kilometers in that
time wreaking havoc across Southern
turkey and Northern Syria
the second massive shallow Quake struck
nine hours later just 60 kilometers
north of the first in the district of
Caravan marash causing further
Devastation to an already fragile region
[Music]
no stranger to earthquakes turkey is
relatively well equipped to deal with
the Fallout from disasters
but in neighboring Syria where there's
already a decade-long humanitarian
crisis it's a very different story
[Music]
displaced people already vulnerable from
fleeing Civil War were living in the
exact region worst hit
but earthquakes don't recognize borders
and responders were faced with the
hugely complex job of navigating this
human tragedy on multiple levels
the Syrian white helmets are a group of
Civilian volunteers better known for
their wartime rescue efforts in
rebel-held areas in the north of the
country
but with external Aid unable to reach
Syria they were the only Emergency
Response Team on the ground
[Applause]
one of their many remarkable rescues
[Music]
little girl called Noor pulled from
underneath the rubble where she'd been
for more than 24 hours
thank God you're safe her rescuer says
as her desperate father stands by ready
to take her into his arms
[Music]
war and earthquakes one trauma following
another leaving a population in despair
the scale of the damage is quite
important it's enormous this is a region
that has been already suffering from a
difficult situation with very weak
infrastructure in hospitals and so on we
have a situation where people themselves
are vulnerable with 15 million already
living in difficult situations here and
beyond that now comes this earthquake
that is compounding the suffering of the
people
those hospitals that survived the Quake
were completely overwhelmed
Northern Syria's medical infrastructure
has been crippled by years of heavy
airstrikes
doctors already struggling for resources
or equipment left unable to cope with
the severity and the sheer scale of the
injuries endured by the survivors
alhamdulillah
foreign
with hospitals full doctors have to make
life or death decisions at the door
the earthquake we started to receive
many cases hundreds of casualties so far
the number is about 100 the martyrs is
about 30 we know and we have information
that hundreds of patients are still
under the place
uh the situation is too bad we need
urgent help
remit the chaos often came the call for
silence as rescue teams listen intently
for voices
hoping for the tiniest of sounds from
underneath the rubble
and excruciating and often never-ending
weight
the rescue and Aid response was more
coordinated in the urban areas of
Southern turkey
but in remote mountainous Villages and
Rural border towns they're still waiting
for outside help
as my team and I traveled into the
disaster Zone we soon came across Ahmet
yilmas at one of the only functioning
airports
having flown here from his home in South
Wales he was desperately trying to reach
the Mountain Village he grew up in
that's the house that's the house yeah I
mean it's completely collapsed he showed
me photos of his brother Ali's house he
tells me Ali is dead and his wife is
seriously injured two of their children
his nieces are missing
we decide to travel with Ahmet or at
least get as close as we could to his
village on our way he got a call from
his niece to say that nobody was coming
to help them
as we climbed up into the mountains it
was easy to see why help might be
hampered these remote communities stood
little chance
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
faced with the unimaginable task of
looking for his missing nieces
I never seen this happen before my left
never and also
there is
brothers and daughters
so your two nieces are stupid
they're missing yes
and has there been any other help from
outside no nobody has signed it outside
but there's no police here there's no
military here
nobody houses you see how many days till
the earthquake happens and then three
days or four days nobody comes
from the from the council but evens
governments even police or Army natives
hatai in turkey's far south eastern
corner
foreign
was one of the worst hit areas of this
devastating earthquake
this location on the Syrian border means
it's become home to hundreds of
thousands of Syrian refugees fleeing War
it was a place struggling to cope before
the ground beneath it shook
with no signs of professional help
people used whatever tools they could
get their hands on picking through the
debris desperately trying to save those
trapped inside
we have no electricity we have any
additional machines to supply our
machines we have no support yet from the
government
we have now Four Towers no one cup yeah
nobody nobody are you here to touch this
understand from the 40 hour I am the one
waiting here for 40 hours no one car is
game and area here to touch now we are
buying here not buying okay just buying
this boy was pulled out
Rescuers took him from his mother's arms
to resuscitate him
they tried and tried but they couldn't
bring him back to life
but there are glimmers of Hope amid the
bleakness
this baby was carried out from a crushed
building alive followed by its mother
she's weak and traumatized but she and
her baby are both alive together they
survived more than 24 hours after their
home collapsed around them
there are questions over how prepared
they were here for a natural disaster
long predicted to happen
but these Rescuers just focused on the
job in front of them and every person
they held down to safety spurred them on
[Music]
as time passes there's less and less
likelihood of finding people alive
[Music]
the cruel winter weather only shortens
the window of Hope
the snow hampers Aid reaching more rural
areas
the Sub-Zero temperatures are punishing
for the homeless survivors
no wonder that warm clothes are photos
foreign
[Music]
Nepal and Haiti but these are mainly
poor countries where you don't expect a
proper response but this is turkey a
relatively rich country but it is just
the scale of the of the tragedy here
that is overwhelmed of the authorities
and as for as for over the Border in
Syria well the question there is really
does the government even care about the
people in those northern areas that it
doesn't control
in many areas of Syria they are still
trying to scrape away at the piles of
rubble looking for survivors
no easy task in a place already
devastated by more than a decade of War
but moments like this one make it all
worthwhile
a newborn baby still tied by umbilical
cord to her dead mother was saved
she is a miracle orphan
her skin Roar from the cold and bruised
from the Crush
she is recovering in an incubator in
hospital
her tragedy is the story of countless
other children in a disaster which
continues to get worse
but 70 of the pair were receiving our
children the SE are as horrific you can
imagine that our health infrastructure
here is already collapsed after the 12
years of war there's severe funding
costs we were already struggling with it
before this crisis hit us right now our
hospitals are not coping our doctors are
totally overwhelmed we've been working
flat out without sleep since the
earthquake hit I mean it's just it's
just disastrous
I don't think
the search in Syria will keep going but
the devastation that sweeps as far as
the eye can see is a constant reminder
of how much the teams on the ground have
left to do
back over the Border in the Turkish city
of Caravan Mirage
a man has been rescued after being
trapped for 48 hours
but he's not relieved he's distraught
[Music]
foreign
the rescue operation is improving every
day but it's too late for so many who
survived the earthquake itself but not
the hours and the days afterwards
president erdogan made a plea for
international help soon after and it has
started to arrive
Qatar a close Ally of turkeys is one of
the 45 countries that has sent Aid and
Manpower
Britain is another
all right let's Head Start we'll get
clear
clear team a team of 77 firefighters
have got to work in Hattie
brought specialist equipment sniffer
dogs and hope there's always hope and
there's lots of evidence to stress
people in the right conditions survived
for quite some time so yeah that's all
we're here for
the British search and rescue team have
seismic listening devices and concrete
braking equipment
so if there are people still alive in
some of the voids inside the wreckage
they stand a chance of reaching them
got lots of information about the type
of collapse the type of survival voids
the likelihood of people in there
but an indication from the dog mate all
we're going to do is recording all that
information now and then deciding let's
send a team here this should be this one
is it is quite dangerous it's going to
take a long time to dig in and find out
there's no clear precise indications
that there's someone live in there at
the moment so that's still what we're
searching for so we're still looking
I've been in the Turkish city of nurda
where workers are making frantic rescue
attempts
the girl is calling urgently for their
help
I've heard my sister crying in the
rubble she says please be quick please
her grandfather is being ushered away
from a scene he can't bear to leave
is she dead he says please be alive
[Music]
with the ambulance on its way the search
team listened for signs of life
[Music]
since yesterday night he tells me we
will find her we will find her and with
that the sister of the missing girl
passes out
everything
more than three days on and it is the
Frantic nature of the search now and the
humanity of it all people willing The
Rescuers to succeed here but often it's
desperate hope followed by the depths of
grief
they didn't hear another voice but that
doesn't stop them waiting
as we left Hope was fading here the girl
who fainted was back she will not give
up
an hour away from nerda in gazientep I
get the opportunity to speak to one of
the heroic rescue workers Samar has been
helping find people since the Quake hit
it's so so hard for me because I'm from
ganzanite and they are my family and my
friends are living in them in here and
and searching and finding someone
and so hard for me because emotionally
also physically is the conditions are so
difficult especially the weather is too
cold it's really so hard I'm social
worker sometimes I'm crying sometimes
I'm laughing and I I try to feel my
better
and I try to see the people yes this is
just the numbers because if the if the
field M40 I can't I can't work here I'm
not okay but I have to be okay
[Music]
foreign
the coming months and years the towns
and cities of this region will be
rebuilt in many cases they may well be
improved to better withstand future
earthquakes as for the people
well they will not recover so easily
their lives torn apart by the scale of
the loss here
will for many
be defined by this tragedy
[Music]
the turkey Syria earthquake of winter
2023 will be remembered for Generations
[Music]
mark down as one of the darkest days in
its history